what's this Mr Matthews huh this Boy
Meets World can we talk about Boy Meets
World and the affection for Mr Feeney
because you turned it down almost twice
right yeah yeah he says you're gonna
make fun of him you're gonna make fun of
teachers and I didn't like that uh whole
idea Finney loves me and he hates you
well it's one of the two
and working with all those kids it was a
very pleasant experience
through the whole show the kids thought
he was English yeah I was a kid from
Brooklyn Mr Feeney
Mr Matthews ET spent a lot of time on
the Boy Meets World set a then 12 year
old Ben Savage told us William was his
teacher both on and offset I might have
trouble like how to say one line and
he'll like say to me off stage oh why
don't you try it like this and of course
the way he says to do it is the perfect
way so I did stay in my dressing room
while they Fooled Around and I was a
serious actor I'm very fond of those
those young actors Williams 124 acting
credits also include playing Dustin
Hoffman's father in The Graduate
and the voice of David Hasselhoff's
iconic car kit and Knight Rider got any
ideas about
I was surprised about the whole thing
with the car that talks for God's sake
that what kind of nonsense is that but
uh my judgment is no good anyway
well his Instinct in love sure Works
William and Bonnie have been married an
astounding 71 years you are a nut
in 1986 their marriage also made Emmy
history Bonnie Bartlett William
they became the second married couple
ever to win on the same night for the
show Saint elsewhere my wife
my real one I want to play from the
night you both won we have your
interview that night oh my gosh let me
play this for you the first thing she
said was how was my speech Yes I said
you were fine and then I said and me she
said well you weren't quite there
that's good I like that and it was for a
show that was pretty groundbreaking when
you think of Saint elsewhere and there
were some folks on there who might have
gone on to have decent careers like
Denzel call the cardiac unit please oh
hey man though don't even whisper yeah
really good actor straight
but uh he did stand up very well so hey
that's the way he wanted to go what is
the key to longevity of your
relationship in Hollywood of all places
lack of imagination
come on come on
all right
I can't imagine being with anybody else
but her well
I could but anyway
foreign